hey guys welcome to this video
in this session we'll be covering some
of the most important marketing books
for
entrepreneurs digital marketing is a
field that will probably never go out of
style
and thanks to this there's always going
to be people searching for new
innovations
and techniques to make the process
easier which means that
alongside courses tutorials and your own
work experience
you will need a little more to bring
about true innovation
that's where marketing book comes in so
let's ask the most important question
probably on your mind
why should i be reading these books the
marketing books that we are going to
talk about here
and the marketing books in general are a
collection of data
and experiences from goliaths within the
industry
these books provide a window to the time
period they were written in
and help you understand how marketing is
still in some ways
extremely similar to how things were
back then albeit with more technology
nowadays
you will also soon see that the books
that we revere the most when it comes to
marketing
are the ones that were written in the
period of the early 60s
to 90s and era where the lives we live
now would have been impossible to
imagine
that's what makes these books so special
the time period and some of the methods
may have changed
but the concepts and rules covered in
these books
have stood the test of time and are
timeless let's now start with number 12
contagious by jana berger a new york
times bestseller
this book is perfect for someone looking
to understand
how to spread ideas increase brand
awareness
or even to grow their customer base it
goes on to explain
why certain ideas products and stories
get shared and grow in popularity why
only certain emails and videos get
forwarded
and much more contagious also goes into
detail about the six basic principles
that contribute
to content becoming viral or contagious
from products initiatives youtube videos
and more it also provides actionable
and specific techniques to spread
information
designing messages and more
now let's talk about jana berger he's a
marketing professor
at the wharton school at the university
of pennsylvania
he's an expert in concepts like word of
mouth
how consumer behavior can be influenced
how stories
ideas and products catch on and much
more he's also been a keynote speaker
in several prominent events and consults
companies
like google apple nike
and more now let's have a look at number
11
hooped by neral this book called a
critical work in the field of
psychological marketing
is one that delves into how
habit-forming products can be built
years of analyzing startups have led nir
to understand the customers can be
influenced
this led to the creation of the hook
model
this book talks about how the hook model
which is a four step process
can enable companies to subtly encourage
particular customer behavior
it also provides practical insights into
how the hook
can be used to create user habits that
will get them further hooked onto your
product
the book also provides steps to create
such a product
finally the book also provides examples
as to how companies like iphone twitter
and pinterest hook their users now
let's talk about nirail starting off his
career in the gaming and advertising
industry nir created different
techniques through which he could
motivate
and manipulate users he also helps
create behaviors
that can benefit users while educating
people
to build healthy habits he is also an
active angel investor in companies like
canva
everbright kahoot and more
now for number 10 we have the conversion
code by chris smith
this book recommended by digital
marketing guru neil patel
is one that focuses on helping users to
increase
sales in this internet driven era
it guides users on tips to perform
online lead generation
and inside sales it also details the
many ways companies can engage with
their consumers
bait media mobile apps and blogs
and how to be effective at it the book
also focuses on leveraging the strengths
of social media
apps and blogs to capture more leads for
less money
like i mentioned earlier the main focus
in this book
is to convert more internet leads into
real world prospects
and sales appointments let's now talk
about chris smith
he's a best-selling author and
co-founder of a blog called curator
which is a social media
digital marketing and coaching company
his work has been featured in a number
of major publications
like adweek and forbes he's also an
in-demand keynote speaker
and is often on real estate industry
lists
as one of the most influential people
within the industry
next up number nine designing brand
entity by alina wheeler
called a comprehensive pragmatic and
easy to understand
resource for brand builders by the
global brand leader of deloitte
this book mainly focuses on the
fundamentals
processes and case studies behind
creating a brand
it covers more than 100 branding
subjects
checklists tools and diagrams
the book also acts as a compendium for
tools
that can make the branding process a
success and some of the best practices
that will get you some inspiration
the book also has 50 case studies
describing goals
processes strategies solutions
and results now
let's talk about the author alina
wheeler alina wheeler is a prominent
speaker who guides teams
with everything brand related from brand
fundamentals
processes best practices and much more
she's also been coaching business
leaders and design consultancies
and has worked with more than 100
companies within the private
and public sector now let's go to number
eight
get scrappy by nick westgard called a
digital marketing bible by publishers
weekly
this book helps smaller companies with
lesser resources
to develop powerhouse results it also
aims to help
teams to think like underdogs and to
leverage the right social networks
and the appropriate digital marketing
tools and to effectively reach
people it also focuses on integrating
the marketing strategy across touch
points
for a unified brand experience both
online
and off now let's talk about the author
nick westgard nick has helped brands
grow
from small businesses fortune 500
companies
to president obama's jobs council
he's also a regular contributor to the
harvard business review
u.s news and world report entrepreneur
forbes mashable and more
he is also a member of the boards of the
university of iowa school of journalism
and mass communication the iowa city
area chamber of commerce and film scene
next we have number seven how to win
friends and influence people in the
digital age
by dale carnegie published in 1936
the book has been number eight on the
list of the top checkouts of all time by
new york
public library despite its age
the many concepts are still relevant and
have been updated to fit
modern requirements the book lays out
powerful
and timeless principles of human
communications
that have impacted millions the
essentials of engagement
affirming what's good connecting with
core desires and other concepts are
elaborated on the book also explains how
to make a lasting impression
to merit and maintain trust in how to
lead
change now let's talk about dale
carnegie
he's a writer and lecturer and the
developer of courses
dealing with self-improvement
salesmanship
corporate training public speaking
interpersonal skills
and much more by the time of carnegie's
death in 1955
his book had sold 5 million copies
in 31 languages and there had been
4 lakh 50 000 graduates of his dale
carnegie institute
now for number six positioning
by already and jack trout this book
released in 2001
called one of the most popular marketing
books ever released
still keeps up with the current
marketing landscape
it details how brands can make their
product an industry leader
it explains strategies that can capture
a large market share
and to build their strategies around the
competitors weaknesses
the book also helps to analyze and
incorporate
data from trends now let's talk about
already and jack trout already is an
author and marketing professional
credited with
resurrecting the idea of positioning in
marketing
jack trout was a marketer who was one of
the founders and pioneers
of marketing warfare theory and
positioning theory
next for number five epic content
marketing by joe polizzi
this book called one of fortune
magazine's top five business book
must reads explains how to attract
customers and lead them to your
businesses
by creating relevant content the book
helps determine what your brand's
content
niche is and what you need to do to keep
their
attention the book can help discover
and develop your content marketing
mission statement
and to set up a process to create and
curate
content it also explains how to leverage
social media and email channels to
create
and grow your audience now
let's talk about joe polizzi he's an
author
and an authority when it comes to
content marketing
he founded the content marketing
institute and launched
several events one among them being
content marketing
world he also won the 2014
john caldwell lifetime achievement award
by the content council
next up we have number four crushing it
by gary vaynerhook
a new york times bestseller this book
helps people build a personal brand
and how to achieve their goals the book
explains the many ways
social media platforms can be taken
advantage of
by organizations to make a personal
brand for themselves
it provides tricks and tweaks to enhance
these strategies
it also provides tactical and
theoretical advice
on how to become a star on social media
and podcast services it also details
examples from real life scenarios and
how they were handled
let's talk about gary vinhoek he's an
investor and
advisor for several startups across the
world
he is also an expert on fortune 500
companies
he also runs vaynermedia a digital
marketing agency that helps companies
like ge
pepsico hasbro the new york jets
and more now for number three
a girl way on advertising by david all
gilby
this book written by david or gilwee who
was known as the most
sought after wizard in the industry by
time magazine
was released in 1983. this consists of
concepts that remain valid to this day
it covers a number of different facets
of advertising
and covers the four foundational
principles of advertising
it also covers the author's experiences
working with many prominent brands of
the era
let's take a look at david ogilvy he was
a british advertising tycoon
and the founder of ogilway and mathur
he was called the father of advertising
he
introduced the concept of branding to
advertising
and focused on the importance of the
creative copy and campaign themes
now for number two the 22
immutable laws of marketing by already
and jack trout this book covers 22
innovative rules that help with
understanding and succeeding in an
international marketplace
the book provides insight into several
concepts that are still relevant today
it also details 22 superlative tools
and innovative techniques for the
international marketplace
and now for number one scientific
advertising by claude c
hopkins this book released in 1923
has been cited as the must read book by
several advertising personalities
like david ogilvy gary halbert and jay
abraham
it's credited with providing the
original description for split testing
and coupon based customer tracking and
loyalty programs
it also details an advertising approach
that ensures
reduced losses from unsuccessful ads and
gains from
profitable ads are multiplied
now let's talk about the author claude c
hopkins
he was known as an advertising pioneer
and was known as
leader in the creation and development
of modern day
consumer brand advertising and direct
response marketing
he was inducted into the advertising
hall of fame
in 1957. and there we go
that's our list here's your reminder to
subscribe to our channel and click on
the bell icon to stay updated
on tutorials live sessions and the
latest technologies
and with that we have reached the end of
this video
i hope you found this informative and
helpful
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here